the line two x plus y equals one is
tangent to the hyperbola x squared over
a squared minus y squared over b squared
equals one
if this line passes through the point of
intersection of the nearest directrix
and the x-axis then the eccentricity of
the hyperbola is so let's just set this
up so we know what this is even asking
let me draw the hyperbola itself
so that is my x-axis
that is
my y-axis and this will be a left-right
opening hyperbola since the x-squared
term here is positive so it will open to
the right like this
it'll open to the right like that and it
will open to the left like i could draw
it a little bit neater than that it'll
open to the left like this
so that's our hyperbola right over there
and then this point of intersection
right over here if you set y is equal to
zero x would be equal to positive a so
this is the point a comma zero this
right here is the point negative a comma
zero x could be plus or minus a when y
is equal to a zero and just so we have
some of the terminology for the
hyperbola out of way a hyperbola will
have two foci
two
focus points so let's say that this is
one focus point let me do this in
another color this is one focus point
right over here it'll be oh it'll be on
this major axis of symmetry for the
hyperbola and let's call that point f
let's call that point f comma zero where
f is the x coordinate and then we'll
have another one right over here
at negative f
comma zero it'll also have two
directrixes
i i don't know what the plural directrix
is but these are lines and we'll talk
about the relationship between the
hyperbola the foci and the directrix's
in a second but these would be lines one
of them would sit right about here we're
just in another color so you'd have a
directrix right over here
and you'd have another directrix right
over
here
let me draw a little straighter than
that these would be for this type of
left right opening hyperbola the
directrix is would be vertical right
over there
and the relationship
is between the directrix the foci and
the eccentricity is you pick you take
any point you take any point on the
hyperbola and the distance from that
point to its closest directrix so for
this point it would be this directrix
right here unfortunately this doesn't
look like a straight line but supposed
to be a straight line so this distance
right over here
to that directrix
the ratio of so this is the distance let
me call it the distance to the directrix
and let me call this the distance
this is the distance to the focus on
this side
the distance to the focus the
eccentricity is the ratio of this
distance to that distance so the ratio
of the distance to the focus over the
distance to the directrix is equal to
the eccentricity so at least now we have
the setup of everything we need to deal
with now let's actually try to solve the
problem so they give us this line y the
the line is 2x plus y is equal to one
and they say it's tangent to the
hyperbola and they say this line point
this line passes through the point of
intersection
the point of intersection of the nearest
directrix and the x-axis so it it
intersects the x-axis where one of the
directrix's
intersect the x and we know where this
intersects the x-axis we can set y equal
to zero if y is equal to zero we get two
x
is equal to one this y disappears you
get x is equal to
x is equal to one-half so it intersects
the x-axis right over there at one-half
comma zero
one-half comma zero and so we know from
this information right over here that
this directrix must be the line x is
equal to one-half actually we can draw
the rest of this line right here it's y
intercept when x is equal to zero y is
going to be equal to one
so that is the y intercept
and so this line is going to look
something like let me do it in a new
color the line will look something
will look something like this
and it will be tangent
it will be tangent to the hyperbola now
our goal is to figure out this
eccentricity and to do that i'm just
going to lay out all of the formulas i
know that we've proven
i think we've proven all of them in
previous khan academy videos related to
parabolas uh sorry not parabolas
hyperbolas eccentricity focal point and
directrixes
and then see if we can do a little bit
of fancy algebra to do this and as you
know i don't like to just regurgitate
formulas that's why we've taken some
pains to prove them but if you're doing
this for the especially the iit exam
where you don't have a lot of time it is
good to have them
very quickly at your disposal so in the
last video we came up with the
relationship between a tangent line and
a hyperbola we said that if the tangent
line we said if the tangent line has the
equation y is equal to mx plus c
and i use c here not to get confused
with the b and the hyperbola we figured
out a relationship between the m c the a
and the b and we got it as
the relationship we showed in the last
video was c squared plus b squared is
equal to
m squared
a squared where once again the m and the
c come from the line it's the slope and
the y intercept of the line and the a
and the b come from the hyperbola so
this is one tool
that seems like it might be useful the
other tool and i proved this in i think
if you do a search on khan academy for
hyperbola and proof or foci hyperbola
and proof you get this right here that
the focal length
the focal
the this coordinate right over here the
distance from the origin to the focus
point along the x-axis or the
x-coordinate of this focal point over
here and you could actually do it for
either one because you're squaring it so
it becomes positive is equal to
it's equal to a squared
it's equal to a squared plus b squared
so this seems like it might be useful in
some way if we use all this information
to somehow come up with the eccentricity
and then the last pieces of information
that should be useful for this problem
are the ones that relate the
eccentricity of a hyperbola to its focal
point
and a and its directrix and so these are
i won't prove them here i think i might
have proven them in previous videos if i
haven't that's something for my to do
but these are pretty well known uh if
you look it up on wikipedia these are
well-known expressions for a hyperbola
is that the extent that the
the
focal point
the focal point is equal to the
eccentricity times a and the
eccentricity is greater than one so this
is clearly greater than a so you
multiply something larger than 1 times a
you get to the focal point and also the
directrix the directrix and this
situation the directrix we already know
is that one-half is that x is equal to
one-half but i'll just write the formula
here
the directrix
distance so the distance from here to
the directrix is equal to a divided by
the eccentricity and we already know
from the first part of this problem that
this is at the point x is equal to
one-half
so this is equal to one-half that's what
this distance right here this is the
line x is equal to one-half and this is
just a known
a known formula for for hyperbolas which
i won't prove in this video because then
it will just take forever now let's see
if we can use all of this information
right over here to solve for the
eccentricity to actually solve for the
eccentricity and here it should
hopefully just be a bunch of algebraic
manipulation i really just want to get
rid of as many variables as possible and
then solve for e
so the first thing i can do is i can
substitute for f in this equation right
over here and then i have an expression
in terms of i have an expression in
terms of e a and b so if i substitute
for f here f squared is going to be
eccentricity squared times a squared i'm
just squaring this over here is going to
be equal to a squared
is going to be equal to a squared plus b
squared and actually let's see if we can
come up with an if we can even
substitute more using this information
over here we know that a
over the eccentricity we know that a
over the eccentricity is equal to
one-half or we could say that if we
multiply both sides by the eccentricity
a is equal to one-half times the
eccentricity so let's substitute that
into this over here so then we get
eccentricity squared times a squared
times a square instead of writing a
squared let's just square this thing
because that's also a squared so it's
going to be times the eccentricity
squared over 4 that's just a squared i'm
just substituting it is equal to the
eccentricity squared over 4 once again a
squared
plus b squared
plus b squared and so this will simplify
to
the eccentricity
the eccentricity to the fourth power
over four is equal to the eccentricity
squared over four plus
b squared and i don't like having these
fours in the denominator so let's
multiply both sides by four
we get the eccentricity to the fourth
power is equal to the eccentricity
squared
plus four
b squared so we have an expression in
terms of e and b and so far we used this
information this information
and this information now let's see what
oh actually
right and this information right over
here now let's see if we can incorporate
this somehow
and this that relates the tangent line
to the hyperbola is useful because we
actually gave us the equation of the
tangent line we actually know
that this equation right here if we
write it in slope intercept the tangent
line is y is equal to subtract 2x from
both sides
negative 2x plus 1. so m is negative 2
and normally we'd call this b but i
don't want to confuse it with this b we
call it c in this formula our
y-intercept is 1.
so this
this expression right over here let's
rewrite it so we have c squared
we have c squared i'll do it in green c
squared is 1 squared so we have 1
plus we don't know what b squared is so
1 plus b squared is equal to
m squared we know that m is negative 2
negative 2 squared is 4
4 times a squared now instead of putting
an a there we already have expression
terms of e and b so let's put this in
terms of our eccentricity we know that a
squared
or that a is the same thing as one half
times the eccentricity or so we can
write this four times the x entries this
is more actually this is an epsilon not
an e
four times we just square this
eccentricity squared
over
eccentricity squared over 4. i just
squared this over here and so these will
cancel out and so we have another
equation that 1 plus
b squared is equal to the eccentricity
squared or we can subtract 1 from both
sides and i want to do that so we can
substitute for b squared up in this we
really only have two formulas now or two
equations
and we have two unknowns so in theory we
should be able to solve for the
eccentricity now
so we have this let's just solve for b
squared so we get b squared is equal to
the eccentricity squared minus 1.
and then we can substitute this back in
for b squared and see if we can actually
solve for the eccentricity
so then this expression up here is we
have the eccentricity to the fourth is
equal to the eccentricity squared
plus four times
b squared which is this
which is
the eccentricity squared minus
one
and now we have a fourth degree
polynomial in eccentricity but let's see
if we can still solve it hopefully
they're not going to give us something
too painful so this is going to be equal
so we have the x-intercept to the fourth
is equal to eccentricity squared plus
four
times the eccentricity squared
minus four now let's bring all of that
onto the left-hand side so we're going
to subtract all of this from both sides
and we get all right it's a new color
the eccentricity to the fourth power
these two over here actually let me
merge them these are this is
one times eccentricity squared plus four
times eccentricity squared so this is
five
five epsilon squared or five times the
eccentricity squared we're going to
subtract it from the other side so it
becomes minus 5 times
the eccentricity squared and then this
is we're going to add 4 to both sides so
plus 4
is equal to 0 and now we just have to
solve for eccentricity now at first this
might seem complicated but this is
actually a very factorable this is a
very factorable polynomial think of two
numbers two factors of four that add up
to negative 5 and hopefully negative 4
and negative 1 pop to mind so we can
actually factor this no quadratic
formula necessary
this is factorable into
epsilon squared minus 4
times epsilon squared
minus
1. negative 4 times negative 1 is
positive 4. if you add the 2 you get
negative 5. and if this confuses you
with the fourth power and a squared you
could do a substitution so you could say
i know some random letter call it some
letter we haven't used yet call it the
letter uh we already use f let's call it
the letter g say you could say that g is
equal to epsilon squared and then this
would become g squared minus five g plus
four and then this just becomes kind of
a traditional factorable uh quadratic
but this is equal to zero and there's so
there's going to be two there's going to
be two solutions over here
actually more than two solutions
so you have epsilon squared minus four
is equal to zero and epsilon squared
minus 1 is equal to 0. this one is
epsilon squared is equal to positive 4.
this one is epsilon squared is equal to
1. if we were to just solve this and not
think about what eccentricity is trying
to tell us we would get plus or minus 2
here
eccentricity and we would get
eccentricity is equal to plus or minus 1
here and now the key realization is the
eccentricity for a hyperbola is always
greater than 1. so the only eccentricity
here that is greater than one is
positive two the other ones are either
one or they're negative so the only
thing greater than one is positive two
so the eccentricity of our hyperbola is
is
positive
two and we're done